welcome to this video playing ocarina ya
kamati know from from spain of course
let's see Kings Indian yeah Kings in yet
and after the last game where I belong
that so badly I like to run let's let's
play let's play very solidly the it
still as some some bite to it
yeah c6 took him a while this is a good
sign maybe he's not knowing the exact
lines yeah this is some unknown a known
line which actually is quite good for
white but then you get it from time to
time black players sometimes yeah get
into this without really am knowing the
theory he cannot take on you fro because
at the end the struck the eighth bishop
age six and wins and this isn't this
curious okay I need to I need to drop
back here anyway he still cannot take of
course and yeah I play a 3 next move on
man and I'm born up for not much you
need he needs to play h6 Bishop e3 and
then take which is also a bit better for
white but probably a tenable position
thus Linus is a bit this the c6 line is
some not not great form for black I
believe y term quite often gets a
position like that where you have an
extra ponent you're a bit uncomfortable
because of the dark squares but it's not
it's not a dramatic issue quite often
now you you can add the enter convert
your palm okay I'm trying to get rid of
this night it's a it's annoying on c5 he
may be can play yeah but 93 is not
really doing anything if he takes my my
okay
the question is should i take on c5 yeah
why not not actually it takes on v2 i
added don't mind dad King takes bc boobs
if I should I should be excellent for
white we've got the two bishops and the
next report I mean on top of that if you
take c5 bc 3 the c5 is going yeah
whitest white ass excellent here this is
another way to go but I thought night a4
would be would be good just attacking
the weakness and no way to protect it
okay yeah I can just I can just take em
take the bishop on c8 and be content
with that so just just consolidate I
would he can play can actually take
everyone now hmm yeah this was a mistake
I should have prevented that because it
is God look before at the end
a stupid very very stupid
yeah no way to know nothing to do need
to do that now that yeah of course from
came from an almost winning position I
got into the same and cannot even play
would be one because of a three
unbelievable
check check hmm I don't really
understand what he's doing to be honest
the time management in everything Group
B to look after I thought you he really
had something now this is again just
better for white he had the activity
getting the pole or maybe he can have
Bishop d6 he can take n play Bishop t6
probably I get it anyway
at least I cannot lose now I really
feared that I would lose it
mm-hmm
hmm ya dumb cannot really get to the
pawn I don't see her so don't see at
least at the moment
just Bishop c6
and now King c5 c6 getting the pawn
yeah it's probably a draw would be
surprising if it wasn't check check
check was I'm not not one hundred
percent sure some way maybe Bishop to c5
and then tried for a breakthrough may be
made muscle black for Fitz on time yeah
one on time but they cannot concede to
draw here because I'm not sure if this
maybe not winning I'm controlling evade
this is this is why maybe there are some
chances to win yeah I needs to go here
not sure
but wait wait wait no it is a drum
matters is always a draw I'm just I'm
just talking on since yeah it is
competive cords it's a draw if I have
it's very easy if I without playing six
he always plays this move and just stays
he doesn't move if i take King takes
it's a complete blockade and I cannot I
cannot make any progress here a king to
g7 theoretically by then it takes only
six it's a row and even if i go here
let's say just for argument's sake check
now we can take but you can always go
back and this is that this is just that
no way to progress here yeah it's a it's
a draw actually I could if I wasn't sure
otherwise I can I do I offer a draw if I
think it's dead but I only saw it
afterwards yeah but I completely lost
control of this position which is a real
shame here this B 3 has just complete
complete nonsense just like GCM and and
it's basically over it's an extra Paul
and I have complete control over the
position very nice and probably winning
you can he can of course you can have
the bishops okay but it's it's just a
very solid extra porn I've got even
ideas to attack those pawns what is
winning him yeah but I bought it and
then he spoiled it back and was slow on
time yeah thanks for watching